we're going to get started in transition
into our workshop Calvin will kind of be
the sage of the stage kind of leading
things then I'll try to monitor the room
so if you have kind of sidebar questions
flag my attention and I'll come around
to you if he's going too quickly or you
have a question that everyone benefits
from being a little bit more grandiose
than your dressers so we stop and
address those things you may or may not
have seen the advertisement that if you
attend this workshop today that you get
a four month free access to Wolfram
Alpha note book edition so if you didn't
see that before here you go the address
at the top is how you redeemed that so
account dot Wolfram calm or deem and
then the code that follows those of you
that have already installed Wolfram
Alpha notebook edition I'm not sure
process wise what this prompts you to do
so if this is asking you to install a
new subscription again you can email me
Ashley B Wolfram comm I can save you a
lot of installation time we can just
flip the subscription you are her to you
have installed to get the four months of
access so if you're prompted to install
something else don't do that just email
me please why I assume what you
downloaded today is the trial so that's
time limited so after 15 days that would
expire but this is for four months so
I'm saying I'm not completely sure
because I have I just saw this
redemption code just now so I haven't
tested it myself I'm not sure if when
you go to redeem that okay perfect okay
perfect
did you use this link though port
perfect yeah okay yeah so to clarify if
you just went to the standard website
and said try now and downloaded the
trial that will be fifteen days but if
you use the math about or the passable
rather site and then use that link it
was already this four month license yeah
perfect okay last thing as people were
filtering in if you have not already
installed Wolfram Alpha notebook edition
it is a large installation because again
it's built on top of Mathematica
however our tech team is here the two
gentlemen that are standing up with us
they have jump drives with it with the
installation that you can start loading
on your machine so please do that so
that you can at least get some
first-hand experience today
cool all right good
all right so this is designed to be a
hands-on session where everyone types
along with us if I'm going too fast or
going too slow let me know but I'm I'm
gonna be typing things bit by bit by bit
and you're gonna work along with me but
the goal of this is just to get a feel
for WolframAlpha notebook Edition do
your first couple calculations and and
gain some experience with it
so looking around the room I can
partially answer this myself but by a
quick show of hands how many of you have
used wolframalpha.com somewhat
extensively Oh strange answer okay less
than I thought okay how many of you have
used Mathematica and have good
experience with that you have experience
and yeah it runs and it gives you
outputs that are useful for your
research and teaching okay so more
Mathematica users then wolframalpha.com
users okay how many of you Mathematica
users have experimented with the
freeform input mode in Mathematica okay
interesting
okay so I'll try to focus a little bit
more than on the the the man behind the
curtain so to speak okay so everyone
launch Wolfram Alpha notebook edition
and when you launch it you should see
the the welcome screen
so everyone launch Wolfram Alpha
notebook Edition and then just hit new
document to get a new notebook so that
we've all got a blank notebook to look
at and if things pop up and start asking
you for keys or logins or whatever make
sure to login or raise your hand and ask
us if you have questions but hopefully
everybody will get to the point where
you're seeing a blank screen here
good okay so let's start with something
super simple 14 plus 71 and hit enter
now for those of you that use
Mathematica a lot you hit Enter and not
shift-enter
so if you hit shift enter that makes a
new line if you hit Enter
that makes a calculation why did we do
that well because the people that are
not used to our notebooks they always
sit ENTER to do things they hit enter on
a web page they hit enter everywhere so
enter is how you do calculations okay
any objections I think we're all rolling
so similar to notebooks the horizontal
line is the spot where you do new
calculations if you just have the
horizontal line and you just start
typing like five to the third power or
something like that
by default the product creates this
Wolfram Alpha notebook input cell so it
doesn't create a Wolfram language input
cell it doesn't create a text cell by
default the default new cell is the
Wolfram language then the Wolfram Alpha
notebook Edition cell okay is there any
is there anybody who's stuck getting
this far or are we all good okay every
everyone else okay with logging in and
getting everything okay good
so next thing let's create a yeah one
quick thing that I think a lot of people
just inherently understood but to make
it explicit one major difference between
Wolfram Alpha notebook Edition and
Mathematica is that Woolf Malph a
notebook edition is using that freeform
input using Wolfe Ralpha so it has to
have an Internet can
action so you can tap back to our server
yes so where you can run Mathematica
just on your machine and not have access
to the Internet you have to have access
to the Internet for a while throughout
the notebook Edition to run yes thank
you that's a very good point and and the
reason why we do that is we are
piggybacking on the very very very good
Wolfram Alpha technology we're in the
background we're updating things not
every major Wolfram language version but
much more frequently so what what
everyday English you use today that
might not work it might work
you know tomorrow or next week or in a
couple weeks not necessarily when you
install an entire new version of the
software so there's a lot of advantages
to that okay so let's go back up to the
top so click on the top to get a
horizontal bar and then click the plus
key to get the cell insertion assistant
and then choose title and then let's get
some experience with this where you can
make a title called hands-on start or
something like that so similar to
Mathematica or our other products a
notebook is a collection of cells so the
divisions over here we have text cells
we have calculation cells but what we're
doing today is just building up our
first notebook which is a collection of
cells so this is a title cell then we
can make a section cell below it so if
we click and get the horizontal bar and
click the cell insertion assistant and
then click section we can make something
like basic calculations lay my spelling
is going to be good today and just as I
showed in the in the last training we've
got the hierarchy of cells now as well
so if you double-click on the outermost
cell that collapses all the basic
calculation inputs if you click the air
or double-click on the outside then it
reveals that again so when you're
teaching and and when I do training
sessions I am somewhat addicted to this
sort of style so I hate it when people
read ahead it drives me up a wall so
what I'm doing presentations I very
commonly have sections with sometimes a
lot of examples but I will tuck them
away a lot
so in teaching when you don't want
students to read ahead this idea of
tucking this away and then revealing it
as you go even if you have the whole
thing pre-typed is really really really
really handy ok let's make another
section cell let's go to format and so
instead of using the the cell insertion
assistant let's go to format and style
and then section but you can see here
that the keyboard shortcuts all work for
Wolfram Alpha notebook Edition as well I
am a heavy user of the alt for all three
alt two sort of thing so if we click and
get a section cell you can do that or if
you highlight the cell on the outside
and start clicking alt one two three
four well let me put something in here
so arithmetic or something like that so
if you click alt one all two three four
etc then you scroll through the
different types of up cells just like
just like Mathematica sorry yes command
command on Mac and and the format menu
should say instead of alt it should say
command as well
hope you Atty mean the people who didn't
have it already installed are about
halfway through the installation okay
got it
oh yes I see yeah yes yeah that's a good
point yeah that's an interesting
suggestion someone from our group is
some from our group taking a few notes
like Zakhar clean okay good yeah so and
that's a good point so me being a
mathematical person thank you for
stopping me here but the arrow up and
arrow down through the sections is the
typical way to do this but yeah and what
he was saying is if you hit return here
you're just getting a longer section
cell you're not getting a new cell or a
different cell you have to arrow down to
get a different cell and then start that
basically yeah yeah it's it's an
interesting suggestion I don't know what
my gut reaction is to that I can see it
being very useful but thinking myself in
a text cell I'm constantly doing
character turns where I want spaces in a
text cell I don't know if I want to have
to do shift enter for that or remember
something that's a good it's a good
suggestion yeah so my gut says I would
like to see a flag that tells you did
you mean to duck to death so that's what
it would help the teacher and the
student and we would rather mimic what
happens in Mathematica for those people
who would eventually transition to that
environment we wouldn't want you to have
to relearn but helping them see through
the process would be helpful yeah okay
all right let's do our next calculation
so if you just start typing let's do
sixteen over 72 and hit enter and this
is from my experience it's one of the
first questions that your students have
which is you know I typed some fraction
in here or something exact if you type
an exact input you tend to get an exact
output if you type a numerical input
like 16 / 7d 2.0 then you get a
numerical output but this is the first
sort of thing that students ask about
which is sometimes they want to do the
former sometimes they want to do the
latter but they will at different times
want to do both next thing let's type
where you can just say explicitly so 16
over 72 two three digits and so then we
get a direct numeric approximation and
then I think this is the first thing
that we've done in this session where we
can see now Wolfram language function so
now we're learning the end function with
square brackets in three decimal places
and things like that
are we good so far
should I go a little faster
I think so I don't know
all right so let's then do another one
where let's do PI to a thousand digits
so I just want to make the general
comment that PI is a symbol built into
the language so this is all based on
Wolfram language it is a it is a way to
take everyday English and turn it into
computation but the computation itself
is done in Wolfram language so PI to a
thousand digits you know we know what pi
is okay let's set a new subsection here
so let's use the keyboard shortcut hit
alt five or command five on a Mac and
we'll call this variables and defining
functions and also before we go too much
farther you should probably just save
your work so unlike Wolfram cloud and
it's even talked about this in the QA
the there is no autosave happening here
if you see untitled at the top nothing
nothing really is saved so if you go to
file and then save as name this
something like Wolfram tech conference
that's a terrible I tend to name things
really really long because I tend to
search through my machine a lot but
that's sort of obnoxious but if you save
it as a notebook then what's happening
is this is saving as a local notebook on
your local machine and as I said in the
you know in the last talk if other
people are using the WolframAlpha
notebook edition on their machines you
can email them notebooks they open it
and then they can do live calculations a
notebook is a notebook is a notebook and
then also I think will enter this world
where the recipients you might not know
if they have WolframAlpha notebook
Edition or Mathematica or quite what
they have and that should not get you
into trouble either yes I believe so yes
[Music]
yeah because they'll also have
authorship so with the player it's just
a viewer current whereas with Wolff
Ralph a notebook edition they can also
create content themselves so when you
sent them their notebook that you did
this very complicated thing maybe they
start at Excel and said wow this was
super cool and I tried this thing they
did natural language but that is a good
point there too yes yeah yeah I would
describe it as I mean there there is a
hobbyist Home Edition of this I would
describe it as a if your brother-in-law
is a little bit intimidated by
Mathematica this is a more approachable
way to look at the stuff that you have
and and do a bit of things himself yeah
so but but as Ashley said the authorship
and the and the changing what you're
doing and really working with it that's
the big big difference between Wolfram
player and this okay
the people who installed starting at the
start of the workshop or live now good
good all right well the only missed
arithmetic so I think you'll be okay all
right so let's practice defining some
variables so let's say set B equal to
five and again for those of you that
that teach with Wolfram language that
teach with Mathematica in a lot of cases
the classes this is fine students can
handle it but there's always a
conversation about what is a single
equals versus what is a double equals in
many cases that's a very fruitful
conversation it's totally right for the
class in a college algebra class maybe
that's not the conversation you want to
have so in this case set B equals to
five that it does what it says it does
basically all right and then let's do
something where we say B squared + 5 b
not equals that's and hit return so a
quick comment here that i'm saying 5 X
I'm not saying 5 star X I'm not saying 5
space X I'm just saying 5 X oh it
doesn't work oh yeah yeah yeah sorry X
correct correct yeah you do have to say
set or define or something like that
that's a yeah we talked a lot about that
if you just say B equals 5 right now
it's it's testing equality and it's
treating it as a symbol so
Minoo that's fine that's fine I went
through the last one very very fast and
this one is the slow ask questions
version so it's totally good okay so now
let's do unset B and and evaluate that
and then I you know what I'm doing
trainings are what I'm teaching students
a lot of times they think about
notebooks in a top-to-bottom sort of
proposition where they think about the
calculations in a very sort of the thing
that the top happens and the next thing
happens and the next thing happens so
this sort of thing confuses them a
little bit where if we go back up here
and reevaluate B squared plus 5b now the
answer that we get is no longer 70 or
whatever it was now it's B squared plus
five because now we have unset B so this
sort of thing is is really really useful
and really powerful in notebooks but it
takes students just the tick to to get
this
all right let's do a function ah yes
yeah it might be a little hard for you
to see out there but the input-output
labels just like in Mathematica are in
order of the session so this is my 81st
calculation of the day and now that's my
80 second calculation of the day and so
yeah and so that's the order but the
order is what's going through the kernel
so in terms of technology the interface
and the thing doing the calculation are
very separate things in really cool ways
and and the other thing too when I
restart this notebook
from scratch tomorrow and evaluate this
top to bottom you do have to think a
little bit about did I set this before
did I set it after you know what's it
going to do that sort of thing okay
let's define a function so if we say set
f of X equals x squared plus 5x plus 6
something like that now we have a
function definition and again there are
a lot of cases where discussing what X
underscore and colon equals like delayed
assignment there's a lot of cases where
that's a very fruitful conversation
where if someone is going on to do some
data science or some programming and
creating user-defined functions and
doing something really neat that's a
great conversation to have sometimes it
might not be so in this case you can
just say f of X equals and then the
Wolfram language syntax is there but if
you want to gloss over it you can one
other thing too on that point there's
this drop-down menu here where you can
start to hide things so if you want to
hide Wolfram
language so hide Wolfram language inputs
so if you create a notebook and you say
hide that then all we're getting here
although I'm not on anything with any
actual outputs which is a bad example
but we scroll up here yeah so this one
we're now we have the B squared plus 5b
and then we have the output but we don't
have the Wolfram language in the middle
so if if you do want to create a
notebook and then tuck all that away
there's an option to do that you can
also hide the query details which is
that drop down menu so the related
computations and the suggestions bar and
things like that so this is an even more
streamlined clean view and then if you
want to get them back then you just say
show all and then they all come back I I
think we would be curious to hear
feedback on which of those you prefer I
personally have them on and sort of
leave them on all the time but I think
my perspective and your perspective
might be a touch different in that so it
would be interesting to know after you
tinker with this for a while all right
but now let's do some something with F
so let's do F of 10 so since this is now
defined as a function we can pass a
specific numeric value through this and
we get a 156 or we can do a derivative
with this sort of typical notation let
me get this where you can see the top
there we go and so now we have F of 10
we also have the derivative of f of X
and then if we really want to push
things a little bit we can say the
derivative of f of X where x equals 10
this is starting if from my perspective
this is starting to be pretty useful
where it's doing more than one thing at
a time there's so you know for those of
you that don't have a lot of experience
with Wolfram Alpha the idea for the
Wolfram Alpha is it takes everyday
English it turns into something
computable which works very very well
for single visualizations that single
calculations it is difficult to react to
multi-step things so if you want to
customize a calculation or you want to
do a bunch of things at once that
becomes very tricky so this is pretty
cool where it's doing a derivative but
also swapping in a specific numeric
value and it's sort of doing it all at
once and so it saves you the trouble of
defining some sort of intermediate
variable or something like that you can
just swap that in let's do one more
variable definition or I'm sorry
function definition let's do set G of XY
equal to X to the Y is that a comma yeah
okay
and then we can use G where we can say
what's G of 10 comma 10 and so that's 10
to the 10th when we feed it through this
function so someone mentioned this in
the last talk as well
the initial examples that we have in the
initial web page they are math slanted
for the original rollout this is a very
useful product for the math that goes
into physics and the math that goes into
chemistry and the math that goes into
anything or just general computation but
you know the the things that we're
showing and kind of the initial release
they do have a little bit more of a math
slant and the things that we've built in
terms of related calculations this
initial release tends to be a little bit
more math slanted as well all right
let's do a new subsection so alt 5 or
control 5 and then let's look at algebra
and then I'm going to type in what I
have when I see students use Wolfram
Alpha comm the website I'm going to type
in the thing that they always type in
first which is graph y equals and then
something but that idea of the Wolfram
language way to to plot things is plot
students often say graph
alright let's take this one step further
let's do a graph of two equations so y
equals two x squared minus two and y
equals two X minus two
it's kind of a lot of twos in that
example so again the the the idea that
we're using two equations here is
recognized there's curly brackets in a
plot which is pretty neat
we also get this nice plot legend here
so that you can see the line is this
orange color and the 2x is the blue
color and so you can tell them apart
really nicely
all right then let's do some solving so
let's solve 2x minus 2 equals 0 for X I
would say this is the other top thing
question that I get from students when
they're looking at the if they're using
Mathematica for the first time which is
they type in solve but they use one
equals here in the middle of the solve
and then they get an error message that
says you can't set to X minus 2 to
something and they get a little confused
so this is a nice way to do a solve but
they use the everyday English that they
use for that and then they can you know
sort of ease into the Wolfram language
alright so so far we've done text we've
done titles we've been done subsections
sorry we've done titles subsections we
have not done text so let's do a nude
plain text cell which is alt 7 oh it's 7
just the same as Mathematica that's
useful on so let's type in here are some
examples in algebra calculus and linear
algebra so one thing for a course where
that you might want to do is you have
this text but you might want to style it
in some way so all the key things so if
you highlight some and and hit ctrl be
too bold that that works or if you
control I to do italics that works or if
you highlight a word and you go to the
format drop-down menu so you have face
you have size you have text color
background color so these key things so
if we want to make this read in terms of
text color
so these key things in the format
drop-down menu for style and text are
there so if you want to make something a
certain font or a different font or
choose your font or something like that
you can do that up here Calvin did you
do it did you do a quick keyboard stroke
you do that or something possibly I just
clicked on the oh yeah so if you click
where there's a horizontal bar and then
click that little plus thing there yeah
yeah yeah I very well might have did alt
7 I can't remember watching so then I
wasn't sure how to recreate it
okay good good yeah yeah yeah and I mean
when when I see people using notebooks I
I don't know if I can quite put a
percentage I would say people brand
brand new click on that plus a lot and
they really like it because it's sitting
right in their face I would say people
use the format drop-down menu the least
often but people use it just to learn
the keyboard shortcuts and then once
they're in week I don't know let's say
week three then people use keyboard
shortcuts so I'm Way past week three so
you'll catch me doing keyboard shortcuts
all the time but I'm pretty addicted to
keyboard shortcuts
[Music]
this
I don't ever do this interesting yeah
that's good yeah that doesn't show the
keyboard shortcuts though does it yeah
yeah it's nice thank you yeah and
background color and size and clear
formatting is sometimes very useful as
well I'll do clear forwarding some
formatting sometimes when I have a URL
embedded and I just want to sort of get
rid of it okay
let's I don't want to get too far I'm
easily sidetracked so I'm trying not to
do that okay let's do an integral of
cosine 2x
okay so the next thing that I want to
show that has been popping up but I
haven't really talked about it is this
bar here for suggestions so the first
this step-by-step solution but what I
want to talk about is related
computations so if you click on this
there's a bunch of things that pop up so
these are all things that when you click
on them it creates a new Wolfram Alpha
notebook input cell and then it does you
know whatever it says so maybe you want
to do you know a definite integral over
a half period or integral from 0 to
infinity whatever a lot of times though
you want to do you want to plot the
function and the integral so like the
original function and then the integral
but when I do that when I click on that
button it creates a new input here and
it says plot these two things and then
it gives me the plot and we can see its
f and the integral of F so these related
computations again they keep you in this
Wolfram Alpha notebook mode where when
you're clicking on them its new inputs
but it's Wolfram Alpha notebook inputs
if you have suggestions for more of
these related computations after we're
done here you know let us know or after
you've played for a couple weeks let us
know because we would be interested in
what you'd like added in the future but
it's a it's a good collection already
so by default no so when you go to a
file a new notebook
it is this mode it only goes back to
Mathematica mode if you get something
that was created in Mathematica and you
open it up here yep yep yep yep yeah and
and that's a it's an important thing so
this this separate installer in build is
not a stripped-down thing it's more of a
we're guiding you through a path we're
guiding the workflow we're not taking
things out of the kernel or taking
things out of the front end and the end
the case with your brother-in-law too so
if you work in Mathematica but your
brother-in-law works in Wolfram Alpha
notebook addition you sending something
you created in Mathematica that by
design it is supposed to work just fine
you can yes I'll say we're a little
young on that so if you just say import
and then a file path it does work I
don't know if I have an example of that
I think it does work but I will just
make the general statement of its it's
for basic stuff and I would say if you
want to get into more data science or
really drilling into data you're gonna
hit that limit where you want Wolfram
language more quickly than the stuff
that we're doing yeah you could do that
yeah
[Laughter]
yes yeah yep that that definitely will
functionally work and it's a perfectly
good use case I think a lot of times
though when we think about this product
we're thinking about it from an
authoring standpoint where they don't
have you to coach them through the
Wolfram language they need something
else to get them started
but yeah technically it'll work good
well I mean yeah yeah I mean it's the
the they still need a subscription to
this thing I mean if they've got this
product or that product there's a
hobbyist version of both and so in a
sense they choose the one that's a
better fit for them or which resonates
with them more which might be Wolfram
language it might be this but I think
there are definite cases for both okay
let's do let's do something where we do
a derivative but a step-by-step solution
so let's type in derivative yeah pretty
good question here so the first time
they tried to render that last example
they got an error message just choosing
it out of the options of related
computations then when they did it the
second time to the plot function
integral it worked
interesting but in the output there was
also a gray box where some amount could
not be rendered you have an idea of why
that is or what it could be because we
don't actually even see anything missing
from what you're showing verses in
history
it says just on every contact if you go
to the evaluation drop-down menu is that
highlighted yes okay does anyone else
have this problem okay thank you thank
you yeah that's a good point okay so
let's finish our derivative here so X
plus 1 quantity squared so there's two
ways to do step by step solutions first
is just by clicking this button which
starts a new Wolfram Alpha notebook
edition input cell so show steps or you
can just type in directly show steps and
then whatever equation you want either
works just fine within the show steps
there's really two moans and I think
there's two very different motivations
to have the mode so if you're working
through homework and you just want to
work through one step at a time so you
work with this by hand you decide it
needs the chain rule you decide that
you're going to you know do the next
step to the next step in the next step
this is a good way to work this out by
hand but check yourself as you go I
think the other mode just the show all
steps is a good way just to figure out
if you've got the right answer and then
just sort of scan through pretty quickly
but from my perspective the one by one
is more useful where students can check
their you know check their homework as
they go
when I've talked to people about this on
the website
several people have told me this and I
find this really interesting but one of
the things that they like to do with it
is use it as a crash course for three
courses ago so if you're teaching a
junior level course and and you need
your students to remember something that
they learned in freshman math and they
don't quite remember it this can be a
you know ten minutes before class crash
course review so it's it sort of gives
you problems and it gives you this tutor
for you I think that's a really good use
case for this so you could start
students out with a couple of these
things tell them to work it out by hand
but to have them double-check it to
Calvin yes could you try doing that as
solve and because there are some steps
that allow you to use hints yes okay
sure sure
yeah I mean if I well let's see let's
stick with something simple here yes
good okay all right so if we start with
solve and then step by step
we can go through here and show ya okay
can you tackle the hints on and off in
this got it okay got it got it yeah yeah
thank you and just to repeat that so
everyone can hear so the hints are sort
of the in-between steps so the idea is
if you're working through this bit by
bit by bit it gives you the hint for you
know big-picture what should you be
doing and then you can practice doing it
and then when you say show the next step
then it says great you should have ended
up with this but it's a nice way to go
through this without it showing you
exactly the the the result with each
step as you go through yeah for autosave
okay yeah Steven was talking about that
in the Q&A I knew nothing about that I
agree yeah yeah yeah so so it it's a
funny thing so in the browser-based
version the save autosave is on by
default but there's not the multiple
undo and desktop there's multiple undo
which is really really useful but not
autosave if it's sort of like we need
we've got we've got two great ideas
there that just need to mesh just a tiny
little bit yeah
any other good step-by-step I should
show okay yeah got it that's good that
that's a notebook edition as well yeah
sorry I wasn't listening convert say
that again convert 102 base to
okay cool oh this is cool okay good yeah
I like the the balanced chemical
equations and so the step by step
solutions there's a lot of that built in
for a lot of different areas sometimes
you think of it as calc one chain rule
sort of things but there's a lot of
depth and a lot of different problems
that it knows I this one I didn't know
either this is a really good one yes
yeah yes uh-huh yes so here right so
when you click on this and you start to
type in here you can hit shift enter and
reevaluate it yeah so you have to hit
shift enter right you're entering
Wolfram language world yeah so in and I
mean we would be curious to hear
feedback about this but one thing we
talk a lot about is the wolframalpha.com
users what is the what is the really
useful bridge where they'll get into
Wolfram language and appreciate the -
for what their what their respectively
good at so this is one thing that we're
doing to encourage that so if they start
with a solve command and then they see
the Wolfram language syntax and then
they want to change it and tinker with
it then they certainly can and and then
they're starting to use and know and
learn Wolfram language yeah Eric
oh yeah
yeah yeah let me yeah we shoot we yeah
we had that we had that for the
WolframAlpha where if you did the wrong
thing there was a little bar that came
up to the right but I don't think we
talked about it for the Wolfram language
that's a good suggestion I think
Michaels left yeah that's a good
suggestion and probably when they hit
Enter
it should say did you mean to hit shift
enter yeah all right let's skip ahead
and do some graphics so I have been
scrolling way up and way down so if you
want to do a new section of graphics and
I'm sorry I just did a keyboard shortcut
again okay so cell insertion assistant
and then section or alt + 4 or command +
4 on a Mac and then the graphics section
so let's do a graph of y equals 2x minus
2 and then let's have it be thick and
red
so this is another thing that's handy
where not only can you plot things but
you can start to style them as well in
the everyday English which is pretty
neat
also for graphics if we say graph
something like 2 plus sine of a times x
squared minus 2 varying a from 1 to 5
that might be unnecessarily complex but
to me I always try to type things that
are a little bit more complicated into
the plain everyday English just to see
if if if things turn out like I think
they should but the point here is when
you use varying then it treats a as a
you know a symbol but it is the it is
the local variable within the GUI here
where we're controlling it and going
from 1 to 5 for those of you that know
Mathematica this works very well with
plots it doesn't work perfectly across
the system so you can't create any sort
of manipulate that you can create in
Wolfram language with this sort of
varying kind of terminology but it's
very very good at graphics and and
initially what people want to do and
what students want to do is graphics so
for the first roll out that's really
really where it sings yeah
axis labels okay let me go back up to
the
what does it want for access label
something like this
ah there we go good it's being too cute
then it's thinking too much thinking
about curly brackets those things that I
just did okay yeah cool yeah that's nice
and gridlines are especially nice -
thank you yeah how are we doing in time
okay
so okay that's pretty good actually
all right let's do let's do some 3d
plots
so if we say plot sine of X times cosine
of 2y or something like that well that's
not going to work
so one thing that's always nice is
clicking on 3d graphics and rotating
them which works in the Wolfram Alpha
notebook edition as well or holding ctrl
and clicking and mousing up and down to
zoom in so those sort of things where
you want to zoom in or rotate 3d
graphics work really nicely the other
thing that's nice too is you can say
something like a contour plot of that
same sine X cosine 2y oops yes
yeah I don't think that's a valid bug
you should be able to spell better than
that okay not a bug but a suggestion
okay so contour plot and then again you
can mouse over this to see these height
values and get that interactivity so a
lot of these things that are really
useful after you get these 3d plots this
interactivity exist in notebook edition
just by default and then things like
creating a table of values so if you say
table of x squared X from 0 to 100 so
what you get back is a list of values
and then you can say graph that or graph
percent so % for those of you that like
this or are used to this sort of
notation % is the last calculation that
you've done so that works in Wolfram
language and if you use to that it works
here as well but you can say graph that
as well yeah I think so
yeah yeah I think so it's I mean you can
get yesterday's price of Microsoft but I
don't have a lot of experience with
getting the time series and then
plotting that
so you're saying price of Microsoft from
Jan 1 2019 to yesterday and then you get
a time series and then you say graph
that yeah yeah so that works pretty well
very well
I don't know I I think yeah I think
probably but I've seen limits with how
far table can go and and I I have bad
habits where I make table just be
Wolfram language and yeah so okay cool
yeah doing some linear regression yes
well yes
although I don't know that this is gonna
work oh well okay it does work so this
is why I say yes ish so there are some
things in Wolfram language where you get
fitted model back so yes it works
and then this is a decision that you
might want to or might not want to make
with students so the Wolfram language
suggestion bar is there as well by
default it is turned off but it is there
so if you if you have something like
fitted model and you want to plot the
fit or you want to do something like
basic properties and you want to say
where's just the well whatever the yeah
so like all those things that if you if
you define a fitted model and then you
want to extract properties of the fitted
model so the Wolfram language stuff is
there I think I think in the future this
will work better in the Wolfram Alpha
notebook edition but right now that is
probably kind of one of those corners
that you hit where the Wolfram Alpha
notebook Edition ends and Wolfram
language picks up with the two of you
would you agree with that
I see okay yeah yeah yeah oh all right
and I have okay yeah good so the answer
was this will improve first second a big
thing that I forgot to mention is we do
talk to quite a few students college
students a lot of times engineering
students who use Wolfram Alpha the
website and they're doing calculations
and they will say to us I've hit the
computation time like it just timed out
I can't do it anymore
so for those students that do want to do
calculations in this everyday English
but they want a really long computation
time this would be a great format and a
great solution to do it
because they're doing the computations
locally and we're not we don't need to
impose any sort of limit for them
bogging down our servers or overloading
our stuffer or anything like that the
this does hit the servers where it's
it's parsing where it's taking the
everyday English and turning it into an
input but then the actual computation
then happens locally
all right let's do a few charts next so
if you want to do something like a pie
chart of just some randomly typed in
data
I must have done something odd here what
if what if what I had thing have I done
here
hmm okay got it so if you want to do a
pie chart or if you want to do a
histogram
and again when we think about the people
who use this product one thing that if
they work with data in Excel you know
that building a histogram becomes a
little bit of a chore and so the idea of
just saying histogram of this and
getting a really nice histogram is
pretty cool
all right and then the second to last
section that we want to create here is
special characters I want to have you
get a feel for this so did it for the
fifth time here okay so plus and then
section and let's call this special
characters and then arrow down for a new
cell so click on this enter special
characters toggle on/off button here so
at the moment for those of you that are
used to Mathematica there's a lot of
typesetting built into the front end of
Mathematica this sort of typesetting is
the starting point there will be more to
follow
basically so one of the next big
projects is 2d typesetting and so
there's a limited collection here but it
will grow over time this this button up
here so the top right special characters
yeah
all right so let's click on the integral
sign so integral of cosine of 2x all
right we'll put a space there
so since that integral is such a common
thing to do I don't need to say with
respect to X or or to be too specific
about it I can just use the integral
sign and then say cosine 2x you can also
then directly click on the step by step
solution button where you get that same
step-by-step solution so if you start I
mean my meta point here is if you start
on the track of using the typesetting
you can still do all the stuff that
we've done so far like the related
computations or the step-by-step
solutions or anything like that the
other thing that we can do so click on
the PI symbol so PI to a thousand digits
so before we enter this but we did
capital P I whereas the PI symbol is
much more descriptive
and then let's do one more let's do a
limit of 1 over beta as beta approaches
infinity
yeah sorry Eric yeah okay and that's
actually a really really good point so
so under pallets there is a writing
assistant palette and for those of you
that know Mathematica really well this
will be a little bit confusing I think
those who don't know any better this
won't be very confusing but these
pallets that you're used to with the 2d
typesetting that really are only going
to work in text cells and title cells in
Wolfram Alpha notebook Edition so the
the the Wolfram Alpha input cells at
this point do not support 2d typesetting
yeah and it worked for you
yeah so we kept it in there because if
you want to make a quiz and have
questions that have nice typesetting
then you've got the pallet to do that
but then for the actual calculations
yeah you've got to stick to the one D
and there's a larger project to support
this all I think both on the website and
in this product so there's a sort of
meta project that'll benefit this a lot
is that a basic accurate description
yeah all right cool
all right then the last thing that I
want everyone to do well last thing a is
file save so save your work if you
haven't saved in a while or if you
haven't turned on autosave as you have
and then let's click to get rid of this
but go to file and then new and then
present our notebook so right now yeah
okay
so right now classics live shows are not
a part of WolframAlpha notebook edition
but the newer presentation tools are so
in terms of workflow and and actually I
do this pretty much as my common
workflow anyway but if you want to make
a slideshow you can either just author
in that environment or you can just
start to grab things from a regular
notebook where you copy cells and then
you paste them in here if you want to
make a new slide so click your
horizontal bar and then click on insert
new slide and then that's what makes the
slide break
so when I gave my last talk I created
the talk in a regular notebook I copied
it into a presentation tool slideshow I
just added some page breaks and then
when you start your presentation then it
takes over the full screen and then it's
you know the full screen for presenting
just like any other presenter tools
notebook oh sorry so I highlight the
cells to the right so I highlight that
and I mean if you right click on it you
can choose copy or I do control C and if
you copy that cell that collection of
input and output cells and then put your
cursor anywhere in the new notebook and
hit control V or paste which it just
pasted the same thing twice but then it
copies into the new notebook and then
you can start to add the slide breaks so
it's it's the concept of a notebook as a
notebook so copying and pasting whole
blocks of cells from this one notebook
to another works just fine and then you
know then of course these are you know
live computations as well of course so
if I go in to start presentation and
full screen mode
not only can I go in here and change
this and reevaluate it on the fly so
it's a live presentation but I can also
add new computations at the end and I
can edit notebooks as well and and I'll
turn that off because it's off by
default
yes correct yes it saves as a notebook
its same notebook format correct so
sometimes I end up with two different
files both as notebooks one which is
just the regular notebook one which is
the slides and sometimes I abandon the
first then I just have slides but in
either case that's that NBD format
because it's always this live editable
presentation document
yes okay good question
so yes you do need to have an internet
connection so the piece that uses our
servers is the piece that takes your
everyday English and turns it into a
computation and then the computation
happens locally but you have to have an
internet connection for that first piece
yes and at this point too I'll just sort
of stop and open it up to general
questions as well because we only have
about seven minutes left so are there
other just general questions yeah
yeah so by default it encourages you not
to do that so if a Mathematica user
sends you a notebook and it's got
regular input cells you can add to them
you can change them you can do things I
think there's probably also a keyboard
shortcut to do that although I can't
remember what it is
offhand but maybe alts 8 or alt 9 or
something alt 0 okay and then select
input yeah yeah but the spirit of this
product is we want this to be a
different introduction to the technology
stack so they will see Wolfram language
after they do the freeform input but our
intention is they see it done and they
can tinker it and then they can learn
the language that way if they want to
author Wolfram language from scratch
that's Mathematica mathematic online so
I that's that's sort of we feel it
that's sort of like the line in the sand
between the two and that different
people will use them in different styles
one won't replace the other it's just a
different different workflow for
different people kind of thing any other
general questions all right well thank
you everyone for coming I hope this is
entertaining
[Applause]
I'll put my email up here as well if you
want to jot it down and if you have
questions or comments or things that you
thought were too drilled in for the
session feel free to drop my email down
yes there are there are one or two on
the website where their example projects
where it goes through kind of the
progression of you start with a question
you explore some things algebraically
you do some graphics things like that so
they're starting to be things like that
but - I mean to turn the question around
a little bit that's what we hope people
will do so we want to we want to give
you these four month licenses have youso
create some things and then let us know
what you created and and we'd love for
you to share it and to help you share it
we're we're really good at technology
you are really good at teaching so you
know we're we're we're we you know we're
realistic about who's good at what when
and we enjoy seeing your ideas a lot
yeah also - you know me myself and a
couple other people are going to create
a reference text that will be a couple
hundred pages it's at least a few months
off but that being the sort of scope of
what what the product is good at and it
will have some examples as well so that
that is in the pipeline as well but I
think that you'll see that more as a
reference text than jumping off point to
creating your own things and less about
you take that and plug it into a
calculus class or algebra 2 class or
something like that